there is no permission from the torat to
have any Mercy whatsoever during war not
on children not on women not on
anybody imagine living for decades under
an open air prison where everything you
do is controlled from what you eat to
what you drink brothers and sisters
please donate as we have come together
one umah to get the necessary Aid needed
to Palestine and Gaza keep them in your
duas but specifically brother and
sisters give from what you love
inshallah and love for your brothers and
sisters what you love for yourself
donate now inshah whatever you can and
allow us to reach that Aid with one um
to our brothers and sisters in Palestine
one day Palestine will be
free brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well insh I've
got the two amazing Brothers Here
Muhammad hijab and zishan we're going to
be reacting to two videos we want you
guys to inshallah hear for yourself
brothers and sisters that I don't know
if he's a rabbi I don't know he's a
rabbi no he's
RAB okay perfect so
exactly by the people exactly and watch
it for yourself and then imagine for a
second if a Muslim cleric for that
matter imagine a ruler a Muslim ruler
which Benjamin nanyu is said something
very similar to this when he was quoting
the amikit which is interesting yes
which is interesting seen as he's an
anti was it he's an atheist he's atheist
he's an atheist really yeah he's an
atheist why is it quot in the Bible why
can't atheists quote the Bible I don't
know I thought I thought they would I
don't know if he's come out as an
atheist you know he he's an atheist is
he even if he didn't say he's an atheist
no I posted on my Community page the
evidence is there oh okay fine all right
let's see what he had to say anyone who
is merciful over vicious people
ultimately will become vicious towards
merciful people there is no permission
from the tat to have any Mercy
whatsoever during war not on children
not on women not on any
anybody
why because if a person understands what
is War and why you're
fighting you'll understand that by being
merciful on on the vicious you will
eventually become vicious on the
merciful he goes on to
mention he goes on to mention uh more
stuff mention the Amit you must remember
what Amal has done to you says our Holy
Bible and we do remember and we are
fighting our brave troops and combatants
who are now in Gaza or around Gaza and
in all other regions in
Israel are joining this chain of Jewish
Heroes a chain that has started 3,000
years ago from Joshua Ben until the
heroes of 1948 the 6 day war the 73
October war and all other Wars in this
country
yeah so how does I mean imagine for a
second if a Muslim cleric for that
matter was to utter anything close to
that he is basically dehumanizing and
they using scripture because we have the
far who keep you know coming and taking
those individuals who have extreme views
in Islam these Fringe views and they
make it like this is what Islam is
you've got a rabbi here not only that
you've got an individual I don't know if
he's an atheist but you know Benjamin
Netanyahu the the murderer the scum who
has come out and quoted the amikit again
and what's it saying in the amikit
what's what's happening in the Bible
when well well well as far as as far as
I know he has a direct commandment for
Moses to go and absolutely kill men
women children babies donkeys everything
for that matter so this is what he's
quoting and this is why we say for
example that this is the ethics of War
yeah if you see in Islam in Christianity
Bible and in the Quran yes God Almighty
has destroyed Nations completely yeah
but that's God doing it but when it
comes to ethics of War one thing you see
in Christianity and Judaism which we
don't have in Islam is when it comes
ethics of what we have clear directions
that we are not allowed to kill innocent
men women children and babies they are
instructed opposite to that which he
just said I mean how does that make you
feel cuz to me it's unbelievable and let
me tell you something it shows you that
there's there is act they're using their
scripture okay and this is why is this
not called radicalism or extremism or
like the same labels that we see in the
Muslim world and remember Muslims are 2
billion almost I mean about 2 billion
people of the planet Jewish people are
are much less than that not even 20
million or something like this right and
so as a ratio as a proportion of the
world's population we'd expect way more
extremism so the point is is that as a
ratio here when when the proverbial hits
the fan and you see people like this
this Rabbi literally with with tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of followers in a country with the
population of 9 million which is quite
significant being followed and liked and
cheered on and stuff like that it shows
you that the sentiment is actually a
terroristic sentiment in large parts of
the Z population there's no doubt about
that well firstly there's an
inconsistency with this whole Zionist
movement I mean you have a a leader the
president the Prime Minister Netanyahu
is an atheist the their first leader
benorian who is an atheist as well then
you've got people within the country
that are the Jewish people and they're
getting beaten up by the IDF we're
seeing clips of this on a regular basis
we've got Jewish people that are
standing up and saying look we are pro
Palestine we this you do not speak for
us there's an inherent dis called of
course and there's clear evidence suest
that we don't want to make it seem if we
talk about all Jewish people oh for sure
I mean that you you can't say this about
them but however when it does come to
the scripture there is no leeway that's
given to Muslims and Islam immediately
this calls for the scripture to be um
Reed yeah reinterpreted modernized yeah
but no one will be saying that about
verses like this uh they'll be called
anti-Semitic even saying Pro Palestinian
slogans like from The River To The Sea
that's known to be a pro Palestinian
slogan it's being criminalized putting
Flags out are being criminalized people
doing stuff I mean the the amount of
freedom of speech that's been curbed
however when it comes to this individual
we're not seeing any condemnation yeah I
haven't seen a single Jewish person um
or a single you know person that's pro
Israel you know at this video and say
you know what I condemn this this is
wrong this is not right but when it
comes to Muslims you have Imam scores of
imams and institutions coming with
statements the media's on them like a
rash telling them you guys have to
condemn this now there's literally a
Witch Hunt where there are people that
are in Pro Palestine marches their faces
are are now being put on the media have
you seen these people these are young
people that have statements that can be
interpreted either or but they are
there's literally a Witch Hunt being
made however we're seeing stuff like
this with how many views I would
millions millions of views and people
are seeing this but yet we're not seeing
any kind of you know condemnation or any
kind of you know what it's this is not
right he doesn't represent us this is
not right and this and that no we fact
seeing the opposite exactly they they
are strategically consistent not morally
and you see that from the far right the
far right will come and say and there is
not a single statement in the Quran or
the Sunnah that tells us Muslims when it
comes to water to harm innocent children
and Muslims will come out and make this
very clear these individuals are not
only saying it they are enacting it in
Gaza as we speak we I have seen Israelis
not all of them are the same I've seen
Israelis who are laughing and mocking
the death of these individuals can you
imagine for a second we have a cleric a
Muslim cleric coming out quoting a verse
of the Quran then there are Muslims who
are enacting on that and then there are
Muslims like us who are YouTubers making
mocky out
that behind bars bro we're finished and
that just shows the double standards and
hypocrisy of these individuals brother
and sisters and Israel is losing this
war this occupying nation is losing this
war and so much so they are buying ads
and they were buying ads a couple of
years ago on our channels can you
imagine a whole state buying ads on our
channels even now in the first week they
spent 72 million on on yeah yeah be
honest how much do we spend here should
I tell you something what we do here we
come buy Burger £5 £15 yeah we got a
t-shirt made £5 £30 £40 what do we
spend no no you know what bro if you
think about it w we come here we sit
down what do we spend and we and you are
spending million and you are compared to
like not just us many brothers in the
YouTube scene and you are still losing
the war cuz it's not about money it's
who is behind inshallah we ask that
Allah is behind our campaign and he
accepts it from us that's it brother
sisters